now I know there's technical definitions
that you could look up for these things
but let's just be honest this is defined
as sexual contact or behavior that
occurs without the explicit consent of
the Vic so when I hear sexual assault I
think of like something great for
something crazy but now I'm finding out
we can lump in all of these sexual
crimes where it's defined on consent
consent means to give permission now on
paper this sounds good but I I think we
can see how in romantic settings this
can be a bit confusing like you need
written permission again can it be body
language like there's so much stuff
between the lines so basically we start
to lose what this really